FBI ! Show me your hands !
You okay, yeah, I'm good just a little nervous. Well. You look very handsome. I just don't want to screw it up
You know you have been preparing for this meeting for six months
You've got this mask you guys a question daddy loves to me dad loves it
Exactly that is gonna. Go make that bacon gross
Mr.. Sawyer is your family enjoying this day very much
So they're shocked you give us the entire floor after you secure the assessment
What do you think of the building with all due respect is?
Glorified security guard. Please the Pearl is the tallest most advanced building in the world you've built a vertical city
But you've brought with it every single safety and security challenge that I could think of we thought this flow was empty so today
Not only have you brought them all indoors, but you've trapped them 240 floors in the air. No one really knows
What would happen if things go wrong?
But I'm just a glorified security guard, so what the hell do I know anyway?
What's one on their 96 floor is on fire you're gonna be just fine. I promise you that.
Tell me how much do you love your family?
If we're gonna get out of here you're gonna have to tell me the truth, there's a reason they chose this building
My family is the only thing that matters to me right now
You